totally not Mark here and today I'll be
talking about a drawing that I did last
week where I took this old iconic pose
from Goku from the Saiyan Saga and try
to draw in daa's new style to be honest
with me uh the most difficult aspect of
this entire process was just trying to
get the style right the pose was all
things considered quite okay it was just
making sure it fit the proportions of uh
Goku as a child um which actually
changes quite a lot at like the length
of his Limbs and all that kind of stuff
you can really see even played around
there with uh uh giving him a tail but
just went for a little more softer
shapes as well with the hair doing doing
doing that kind of like uh doing King
Kai's uh symbol on his back was by far
the most work in this drawing it was it
was very annoying and I always end up
drawing the faces too white I'm really
bad at it so uh uh yeah the entire
process was fun pretty challenging
overall there was no real part that ever
kind of stumped me and the daer designs
are actually really uh illustrator and
animation friendly so it was really easy